this is a production of Cornell
University Thank You Gareth I may be
that the chair of nbnb but I love being
a member of this field so thank you for
having me thank you for sharing your
students with me it's been a great ten
years and and I look forward to stepping
down as chair and being a more active
member of your field and getting back to
enjoy more of my science the themes of
research in my lab are multiple I'm
interested in how volatile mediate
interactions across the full spectrum of
positive neutral and negative
interactions so we look at how volatiles
might mediate obligate mutualism whether
there's any whether there's private
channels that evolve between plants like
figs and fig wasps or yucca and yucca
moths
we also study and this is like obviously
an honest form of communication between
two intimately tied mutualists we also
study dishonest communication these are
not flowers these are platinum dung
mosses and so they are along with cycads
and a few rushes some of the few
examples of plants that have
independently evolved flower like colors
of combinations of color and scent and
other traits that attract animals to
move their propagules in this case
spores instead of pollen we also study
sort of third parties in the evolution
of evolutionary shifts of phenotype many
of you know Kyle Martin and his thesis
work is involved in whether microbes
lend a hand in and shifts between sort
of classic beetle and be pollinated
flowers - flowers that mimic carrion or
feces or rotting or fermenting fruit or
yeast and finally these night blooming
flowers that I'm going to talk about
today which are found throughout the
world and are pollinated by hawk moths
those are the first plants that I
studied in my thesis and postdoc and
largely because they're so strongly
scented at the time the analytical
methods I used were not very sensitive
and they gave me the best chance to
really
you confidently sample volatiles now we
can sample almost anything um so here's
the outline for today's talk I'm going
to introduce you to little laws a
ubiquitous common scent compound that
just happens to be a major player in
night blooming flowers so I want to set
the stage a little bit for understanding
this compound in its distribution I want
to talk about the project this is the
first talk that I'm giving on a project
that's just about to end five years of
funding from NSF on a program called the
dimensions of biodiversity it's a big
collaborative project 5 P is 2 million
dollars five years it's a chance to
really build something and so you're
going to get the first glimpse of what
we've been learning from this project so
I'm going to set the stage for you of
how we designed it what we were trying
to what kind of question you're trying
to answer
I didn't want to home in on one single
endemic species prairie species in
Colorado you know thira hiring Tony I
which I've brought along with me as I
speak I'm going to pass this around it's
nice to see the plant which work on
trees or cycads you can't always do this
but this is oenothera herring Tony I
star of today's show and I'm going to
drill down deep into how oenothera
herring Tony I interacts with its
friends and enemies across its known
distribution in Colorado and then I want
to finish up by scaling up to the
phylogenetic scale and looking at the
genus oenothera at least in Western
North America and asking if some of the
patterns and processes that we think
we're discovering and even in oenothera
herring Tony I are also shared with its
closer and more distant relatives so
that's where we're going today let's
begin by talking about little oh how do
I know anything about floral volatiles
where do we start there are many ways to
concentrate and collect volatiles what
I'm showing you here is a kind of
equilibrate in method for the for
today's talk we actually collect odors
over time so we get emission rates but
the whole idea is that you trap or
adsorb volatiles onto a substance that
you can either aleut with with a solvent
or
you can strip thermally into a gas
chromatograph and so what we do is when
we collect our volatile samples which we
optimize through trial and error for a
given species we inject them into the GC
I use two different kinds of GC columns
to separate complex blends and then we
always need a detector and the detector
we use is a single quadrupole mass
spectrometer and so if I do a good job
my chromatograms look like this and each
peak this is time and temperature this
is abundance of signal and so each peak
presumably is a single compound and how
do you know what that compound is you
get the mass spectrum and mass spectrum
provides you with a hint in this case
this is a classic mass spectrum for
today's compound of interest lintel
which is a monoterpene alcohol but
getting a mass spectrum isn't an
identification it's just it's just a
suggestion what you do then is you buy
the standard or you make it if you can't
buy it and you co inject it with your
sample and if they share a retention
time you do it again on another compound
another column another stationary phase
and if they're always Co alluding onion
and then you go and look at the possible
isomers or the other compounds with
similar mass spectra and you demonstrate
to yourself your own satisfaction that
they're not all Co alluding at 11
minutes or whatever this is okay and so
you can go on to use IR or NMR to
identify these things but there's a kind
of Beatles Greatest Hits of floral
vowels nails there's 1700 that have been
identified but the same 10 or 20 to show
up all the time and little all is about
number six okay
so although today's context is night
blooming flowers pollinated by moths you
can find lintel all in all kinds of
diurnal flowers and orchids in early
Daphnis blooming and you know myth the
mediterranean etc which so one take-home
message is going to be that the rolls of
floral volatiles are often context
dependent the ecological functions often
have to do with dosage time of day or
night
who's the receiver what's the community
context what's it associated with
honest or dishonest pollination services
etc okay so if we think we have little
all then we need to start looking for
patterns I always want to do justice to
Roman Kaiser
there are literally thousands of great
chemists over the last 50 years who
allowed us to use capillary GCM and mass
spec as a way of identifying volatiles
but really only one of them translated
the vast knowledge from perfumery and
essential oil research into floral
biology and that was Roman Keyser söze a
guy who worked for jeeva down a perfume
company in Switzerland traveled the
world looking for new odors for his
company and had carte blanche from his
employers to publish his work so he
wrote these gorgeous books where he
shows his organic synthesis and he shows
the chromatography and he was so far
ahead he was so Mozart everybody's Sally
areas that he just shared everything and
so as a graduate student I met him and I
learned a lot from him that I couldn't
have really taught myself so what Roman
Kaiser did first is he hid all of the
usual suspects for perfume people like
white knight blooming flowers they smell
green coffee
citrus honeysuckle gardenia jasmine etc
okay and so he kind of did his own
mental principal components analysis and
found there's this guild across the
planet of white semi-tropical night
blooming plants that all smell like
gardenias and what he found is that
there's a core of lentil all neural dole
farnesyl these are turpenoid alcohols
I guess the third they're um they're
soluble in nectar so they could be
flavors as well as since and then he and
then to that core he found things like
aromatic alcohols and esters lactones
etc and that adds some of the spice and
difference to these different compounds
so these different floral Accords but
Linda law was almost always there and
when I became a grad student this is
what I read I did a study of my own with
a National Geographic grant and a
Fulbright my first sabbatical was in
South Africa about 12 years ago and we
comparing guilds of night-blooming
hawkmoth pollinated plants at the same
latitude on opposite sides of the planet
in Argentina and South Africa and what
we found was that Linna law was present
and a lot of these plants and their
their floral tubes and their and their
morphology was all you know sort of a
textbook example of conversion evolution
Hawk moths are universal they can fly
across oceans and so they're sort of
kind of selective pressure that they
bring upon flowering plants doesn't
really differ that much between islands
or continents etc um and at that time I
became aware that little law was chiral
and just because I was finding it on and
in my chromatography didn't mean I knew
which little while it was and I had to
invest in a chiral GC column and in fact
many compounds that flowers produce as
volatiles have chiral centers and
because insects respond differently to
them their receptors are often tuned to
the left-handed or right-handed molecule
you kind of have to go that extra step
and identify which enantiomer or
enantiomers you're working with so this
is just a slide to show you I'm not
going to dwell on about chemistry very
much today but the structural genes that
encode little or a part of a huge gene
family the terpene synthase family the
one I worked on as a grad student in
Clarkie or Brewer i with iran petritsky
was an S + little all synthase and then
the ones that are more common in the
literature from tomato and mint are -
limb ll synthase and they are not each
other's closest relatives as in this
gene family so this is just to show you
that many structural genes and their
enzymes that are responsible for for the
biosynthesis of specific volatiles are
revolving repeatedly okay and so putting
a name on them little ol synthase
doesn't actually mean anything in terms
of their sequence similarity there's a
lot of homo pleaseyou there's a lot of
repeated and parallel evolution in this
gene family okay
there are many ways to make these
compounds in other words alright so
there's the introduction now let's talk
about hawkmoths a little and why this
matters
you can't start you can't read a
textbook on evolution without Darwin's
star orchid from Madagascar and it's 23
centimeter nectar tube and the predicted
hawkmoth Santha pan morgan i and there
have been a lot of people including
onder's nielsen who have based their
careers on following darwin and
proposing that well okay this is an
example of fishery and runaway selection
but it's not sexual selection now it's
flowers and pollinators and so how do
you get a tube that long and a tongue
that long it might be this cycling of
you know you withhold the nectar you
make the animal shove its head into the
flower more closely so that it transfers
pollen more effectively and that then
then mutants of the moth have longer
tongues are more effective at doing that
in the plants and moths are stuck in a
cycle of longer and longer tongues and
tubes this is in madagascar these things
happen on islands this made a lot of
sense in 1993 and so we've done a lot of
work on the moth side of things this is
my first grad student joaquin boy ray
and what joaquin did in a kind of
Tinbergen desk way was work out what's
the whole sequence of it with once you
get a motivated hawk moth what are the
sequence of events that gets it to put
out its tongue approach a flower and
drink and these are all experiments that
Joaquin and I and and others have done
together over the years and published
and floral scent is involved in many of
these early stages of getting a moth to
recognize a bright object as a flower as
well as guiding its tongue and lintel
all is one of the compounds that we've
shown and others have shown like Jeff
riffle to sort of release this searching
and probing behavior in moths so in fact
while I'm talking about little all I
want to pass around some little wall for
you to sniff some of you familiar with
it it's in bergamot oil Earl Grey tea
fruit loops
you can pass these around and this is
the racemic mixture this of you who
really want to know what Janani
enantiomer it is okay and so we learned
a lot over the last decade about how
Hawk moths respond to flowers and how
they might affect that kind of selective
pressure on longer nectar tubes and flow
and strong overstated floral scents
the problem is in really ecology just as
in courtship between animals third
parties make a difference there's a lot
of eavesdropping that goes on out there
it's so guppies well-known john endler
studies where guppy males that live in
streams that don't have cichlid fish
have the most wonderful orange long
flowery Fantasia tails and they attract
females and win them as mates but when
the cichlids are present as predators it
can't have those big tails because
there's those are the ones that sickles
will eat first so there's always a sort
of balancing selection on how how how
while B can you display without
attracting enemies and in flowers that's
been shown repeatedly over the last 20
years that floral displayed the
pollinators is often checked by third
party enemies that are attracted to the
flowers and for today's talk the enemies
that you need to know about are these
little moths okay so the genus is mom
feh the family is the mom today they're
related to yucca moths sort of broadly
and they come in three flavors
ecologically they are there are some
seed predators that the caterpillars
burrow into the ovules into the lope
they live in the locals and then they
they finish eating all the seeds and
they spin a cocoon so kind of like a
young come off and then their bud Gaugh
lers once where the female moths lay
eggs on the bud the caterpillars go into
the bud and then emasculate actually
keep all the sex organs and and defecate
into the flowers so there's a huge
fitness loss in both of these cases and
then what I'm not showing here is that
there's also
leaf miners I think the ancestral
condition and the mambas are to mine
leaves or just been webs around meristem
and then use that as a home so they're
all kind of galling actually but they're
specialized
in immortalise and particularly in
western North America where the honor
Gracie has a radiation with the repeated
desert off' occasion of the continent
you get these guys showing up again and
again in different hosts okay so the
Darwin Nielsen view of coevolution is
you have this binary you have the moths
and their pollinators and the
relationship between tongue length and
tube length might go vary with latitude
or altitude but those are the sources
thoughts of selective pressure okay and
these should match each other in nature
and so this is almost like an isometric
scaling right you scale up if you have a
Manduca you scale down if you have a
highly as an Idaho instead of Arizona
because it's too cold at night for these
big guys and you know here you're making
OSA mean and little all and various
amounts that are proportional to the
surface area of the flower that would be
great if it were true but it's not um
when we did work on this species
oenothera SS potosi in Jackson Hole
Wyoming horrible place to work the bomb
foe well here hi Lee's caterpillars okay
so this white line sphinx moth is a
great pollinator but if there's a price
it lays eggs on the buds of the flowers
and their caterpillars eat flowers okay
and so there the flowers are staying
open in the morning there they're
opening up more broadly and they're
losing little all and making geraniol
instead and the pollinated by these huge
antha fara bees brilliant wonderful
silver beads but very long tongues you
have to get up at 6:00 in the morning to
see them but they pollinate every flower
and in Moab Utah two getting hammered by
these mom fogies and what they're doing
is they're slamming shut the flare of
the flower because what we learned is
that if the female moth mama can get in
and get a drink of nectar they come
running out they drop into the rosette
and they start laying eggs in the bud
primordia by the time those caterpillars
has there's a nice developing bud for
them to make a gall out of okay but if
they can't get that nectar meal they'll
move on to another plant so this
directional selection here to slam that
shot and they lose little all as well so
before you even began the study we knew
that there is geographic variation in
not only scent
also flower morphology and it wasn't
just isometrically scaling up and down
with pollinator there's something else
going on here
so John Thompson's view of coevolution
it's about Geographic mosaics where some
populations the predator has a stronger
selective effect than the pollinator and
and and then the flowers respond
accordingly in evolutionary time in
other populations the predator isn't
there because it's got a parasite or
because there's another host plant
that's even better for it and those
plants are released from that selective
pressure and they can more directly
match the morphology and the sensory
biology biological needs of the
pollinators and so what Thompson
suggested is that there should be a
homeles aook across the populations of
these plants where there's mismatched
traits with the pollinators and other
places where they're matching the
pollinators really well depending on
local selective pressures okay so we
wrote a grant to the dimensions of
diversity program and got it on the
first go there's only time in my life I
got a grant on the first try and this
grant had been this proposal had been
submitted as a regular grant for you
know for three previous years as a pre
Purple's Abijah slam fair pour go away
good science if you know this is not
transformative you're going nowhere and
at least I had tenure all right but but
for those of you don't know the program
which i think has just ceased is so
interesting because it takes the normal
amount of funding and couples it into
cobbles it into a team and extends it
from three to five years if 5p is
maximum of two million dollars and so
the criteria are that you study
diversification or diversity on three
different scales
okay functional genomic and phylogenetic
and so your job as a grant writer is to
is to convince the panel that you've got
that and that it matters and that that's
going to tell a story that any one of
those approaches isn't going to tell and
that's what we did so the way we
outlined it was
- sort of I - - - to model intensive
surfing we're gonna choose one focal uh
species in you know thira and really
nail it study stay the whole range okay
so we wanted an endemic something that
wasn't sound over ten states and but
really understand what are the
conflicting selective pressures from the
enemy and the friend are there hot spots
and cold spots are there mismatches and
the traits if we standardize the way
that we collected our data could we see
that etc and then the second part would
be that we would start moving backwards
into the into the lineage and start
looking at sibling species are couples
of species and different parts of
Western North America and ask - the
patterns that we saw here in our focal
species actually are they are they
shared in common across the lineage to
which it belongs and then we wanted to
take a really broad look at the end and
ask for the whole genus oenothera in
fact for the whole family on a gray Cee
and for the whole lineage of moths that
give rise to Mom feh you know are they
Co speciate is this tit for tat
coevolution are they locked in an arms
race are there other things that we
didn't anticipate like life history
strategies or the kind of fruits that
they make that might lock out a mom fall
off if it's trying to to use fruits as a
place to live etc I mean you know thira
don't change their flowers that much but
they change everything else there's no
you know fear of trees but there's lots
of diversity and floral form okay so let
me focus now on what we learned from our
focal study so we decided to work on
this species oenothera herring Tony I
it's an annual and it's self
incompatible so we could study its
lifetime fitness in a single season we
could grow it obviously I passed it
around it takes a while to bloom but
they're very very happy in terracotta
pots they live only here in the Arkansas
River drainage this is their whole world
okay and there's about 25 or 30 known
populations we hit most of them so
Chrissa scogan was the driver of this
word chris is a conservation geneticist
from Kent whole Singers group at
University of Connecticut and she got a
job she grew up in far
and wanted to get back to the Prairie so
she got a job in Chicago Botanic Garden
and we started studying this prairie
plant here's what it looks like in the
field and so what did we do we we
standardized our collection of
pollinator data of herbivore data of
floral scent and nectar and flower
measurements across five or six years
even before we got the grant we started
working in two thousand eight and nine
and so they are pollinated poorly by
large moths because they don't quite fit
they're pollinated extremely well by the
white line sphinx which is also laying
eggs on them and then they're visited by
these pollen scavenging bees at dawn
that do nothing good for the plant
they're one and done if there's a one
flower they carry all the pollen eat and
carry and go straight to the nest and
lay an egg on it so they are pod their
pollen thieves and across all these
different populations there's all kinds
of variation in the relative abundance
of bees and moths but what we found was
that there was no variation in their
identity okay so also from Colorado
Springs and Pueblo in the foothills of
the eastern of eastern slope of the
Rockies all the way out into the into
the Prairie they're basically getting
the same friends the same enemies the
same ecology even though there's some
variation in the sort of eat affic
ecology there okay so our first round we
had twelve populations 13 15 to 30
plants for a population that's a lot of
of chromatography and we found something
strange but out in the south east the
flowers almost never had little all okay
whereas in the northwest
and down into volson berg Linda law was
a major peak okay and so this wasn't
subtle there was a complete drop-off as
you leave the foothills and go out onto
the Prairie and there could be a lot of
explanations for that that aren't
adaptive but we don't often see
something like this and we thought you
know going from a major peak to nothing
is interesting we need to follow up on
this and so we did a couple of unbiased
um surveys and statistical analyses just
to make sure we weren't guilty of
circular thinking we weren't too excited
about lentil all it could be all kinds
of other things going on here so we
measured everything what you see here
are all the floral volatiles and
everything in gray is a measurement
flower flare to Blanc Corolla diameter
her kaga me and we and from all these
populations and then we put them into
random forests which is a machine
learning algorithm which tells you what
variables are responsible for separating
populations out from each other
statistically and so what you look for
is a Gini coefficient and the biggest
one by far was our friend our - Lin wall
okay there's another floral volatile up
there Jasmine lactone and then there's
some floral morphometrics that are
giving larger Gini coefficients but the
rest of the volatiles are pretty paltry
okay so that's good
how do I know what this is here's the
chromatography so Florence is in the
foothills and there's a big little peak
there's this mass spectrum again David's
Canyon is out by La Junta on the on the
Prairie and there's no little all at all
this is presence/absence
okay and then the rest are kind of
typical flower volatiles osa means carry
off alene there's a Jasmine lactone that
makes these things smell like gardenias
etc fennel seed and I trial with lack
which lentil little is it we bought a
chiral column here's the racemic mixture
Sigma R minus S Plus here's coriander
which is S Plus only here's our minus
only which you can buy from Sigma and
here's the oenothera with and without
the spike so it's definitely making if
not completely all our - then mostly all
there's a little bump here not sure
it's also making a little bit of S Plus
but it's hugely dominant R - okay it
drift what's going on these police tuddy
18 athira herring Tony I because that
part of Colorado is getting hammered by
human change the cities of Pueblo and
Colorado Springs are growing in all
directions there's a lot of light
pollution
hawkmoths can't come to flowers if
they're flying around stadium lights you
getting eaten by bats so we thought oh
there could be some local pub you know
adrift
if these populations aren't getting
pollinated by moths answer as they are
there's there's did this amazing gene
flow FST is tiny across these 25
populations we honor Agra wall developed
micro satellite primers free and if
you're a by Ennis which is a common weed
around here and they work green ethera
herring Tony I and yeah this result
shows that there's huge amounts of gene
flow between all these populations and
when we look at the structure analysis
and we look at you know the alleles for
these micro sets you know there's
there's sort of tacit support for maybe
three conceptual populations but there's
no private alleles okay
there's no evidence that would make you
think Rob this is drift you know it's a
neutral trait
give it up all right it's not what's
going on here this gene flow across this
whole region okay and this is just
another way of doing that this is a qst
versus FST looking at quantitative
variation in greenhouse grown
heritability type study comparing it
against FST and only lentil all for all
the scent traits and flora morphology
only lentil all in the Jasmine lactone
come out looking you know significantly
higher than what we'd expect by by
neutral neutral models okay so it looks
like it might be adaptive the the the
variation in lentil all might be
adaptive all right so let's look at the
map we filled it out we went back first
year we got the the grant we went back
and hit the other populations so now
we've got 19 populations with micro sets
and floral scent so the colored pie
charts every time you see yellow that's
the proportion of plants in the
population that had lentil all okay or
the amount of lentil all in the floral
scent on average so
you see that in the northwest they're
really putting out a lot of lentil all
and that Peters out in the southeast
okay and so one of the questions was it
is there a difference upon ears I
already showed you a slide showing you
the best not true and so in fact when we
lump all the little producing and non
producing populations together and look
at their average visitation rates for
hawk moths and for bees there's no
differences here okay these things are
almost uniform across their range so
they have gene flow and they have the
same floral visitors and pollinators so
for you to have a different trait in the
face of all that also suggests that
you've got something adaptive going on
so the next question goes well what
about enemies okay
hi leaves is visiting the flowers but
they're also turning around and dropping
eggs on them so what if the herbivore
pressure from the caterpillars of high
leaves might be a problem as well as mom
fuh okay so then when we look at at the
the caterpillars and eggs
this is eggs of white line sphinx
there's a lot more eggs on the plants
when there's no little okay when there's
little all there's there's relatively
few eggs so that's interesting and here
what we have is bonfá seed predation so
the proportion of fruits that have mama
in them and so when little all is
present there's more of those fruits
that are getting hammered okay so
there's something weird going on here
that little all might actually help the
plant fight against Kylie's might be
calling the third trophic level it might
be calling an egg predators and first
instar larvae predators to remove those
guys but little all may make the plant
vulnerable to Samantha okay so then the
question is you're assuming that they
can spell it you're assuming that they
care you know go to the wind tunnel into
a bioassay
we can do that with Halley's because we
have it mama is a wild animal we can't
yet raise it so Jeff broadhead ran some
electron tena Grahams and so what these
are is here's here's the response to
hexane which is nothing special but
here's the antennae responding to our
plus little aw okay and that's a nice
flection that's a good-sized amount
that's that's a one in 1,000 dilation of
little oil in hexane and here's mama
Antony responding to the same stimulus
not very much to hexane and very very
nicely to our - little wall here it's
responding to a rolled-up flower petal
in a Pasteur pipette so that's the whole
blend so this is just proof of concept
that they can smell these things okay
doesn't mean behaviorally that they like
them but at least they can smell them
what are the units the vertical units
are millivolts and the horizontal are a
time in seconds thank you the red bar is
the duration of the stimulus so we're
puffing an odor over an antenna and then
stopping the puffs okay so these are a
half second H and these are a second
each thanks all right so here I want to
show you a great video that that's sold
by Buena collection just a few days ago
of how highly is handled flowers this is
the first visit this moth has never seen
this flower before okay and so you can
see the amazing contact that it made
with the stigma and with the anthers
pulled off a lot of pollen on its on its
legs we see this in the field all the
time all the time this is this was
actually done in a wind tunnel
what's the dot this is a satay spike
with a with a septum on it and this is
the segue into a field experiment that
we did where we we added little all to
flowers that didn't have them and so
that's what Sol is doing in these
experiments she's flying moths to
flowers from the David's Canyon
population that doesn't have lintel all
and she's adding lintel all to half of
them and not to the others and asking if
the mods care okay now here's the other
star here's mom feh I've shown you still
photos of her but you need to see how
she behaves okay look at the antenna she
is drumming her antenna on the surface
of the petal this is at dusk the same
time that hylians visits the flowers
pollinator and enemy responding to the
same shoes
okay and what she did later on in that
sequence is she went all the way down
that tube took a drink came out and
dropped an egg I wish I had that
unfilmed but we've seen it now a hundred
times so what we needed to do was an
augmentation experiment it's hard to
knock in traits to a plant that you have
that you haven't worked with you know
genome weekly but we certainly could get
the emission rates right and add them to
the cut to the plants out in the field
so this is David's Canyon it's a short
grass prairie it's pretty amazing
open place we supplemented lentil all on
flowers every day for about five weeks
seventy percent of the flowers got got
lentil all we measured herb every the
number of eggs that I'm of caterpillars
the damage we looked at pollen
deposition and removal from flowers we
collected all the fruits to score the
presence of mom for caterpillars and
their feces and and how many and loss of
seeds etc okay
and this is just to show you that the
augmentation worked all right so we're
adding odor at time zero and then an
hour later we're collecting it and this
is just a slow decay curve over the
whole night and then after sunrise the
emission rates increased a little bit
because it got warmer but basically it
can these plants continued the
treatments continued to emit little all
through the night okay so it wasn't a
15-minute experiment which would have
been an easy criticism we nailed not
only the first hour when both friend and
foe are visiting the flowers but we kept
it going all night all right so we're
going to use path analysis here to show
you what happened when you add little
all it increases pollen deposition okay
so that's a positive coefficient here a
significant coefficient probably because
of more pollinator visitation we're not
sure because we couldn't be there to see
all of them but that's what makes sense
the bees never deposit poem so is
probably the hawkmoths lintel all
edition of lintel I'll also
significantly increased infestation by
monthly okay so the plants that don't
make lentil all and we jacked up the
number of mindful larvae we were finding
in the
the other thing it did is it knocked
down the number of caterpillars but not
the number of eggs so adding little all
didn't reduce over position on the plant
by female hawkmoths what it did is it
reduced the survivorship or the presence
of the caterpillars once they hatch from
those eggs we don't know if that means
that they left the plant or they got
killed okay but they weren't there and
then
so here's putting it all together that
lintel has a positive effect on Martha
which has a negative effect on seed
fitness so this is a classic path
analysis you know result the enemy of
your friend of your enemy is your friend
etc and it suggests that what we're
seeing in the southeast part of the
range where we did this experiment is
that Lin allows a liability that if
flowers were to make it there they would
incur fitness loss buy more seed
predation okay so we went back to the
Carter where the Marfa infestation was
highest and that's this road down here
interstate 25 down to Albuquerque okay
and these populations down here had the
highest mom fed infestation so we went
went back the next year 2017 to these
four populations or five populations and
we did a correlative study this is a
phenotypic selection study where you
regress a fruit set and seed sets you
Fitness against everything you can
measure flower size flower number lintel
all emission rates etc okay now here's
what we found there are five populations
all over here in the serve Death Valley
from mom feh all these other traits
Corolla diameter flare to blank for
Kagamine nectar volume sucrose the major
four compounds none of these departed
from null expectations and any of the
five populations except lentil all and
it happened only in rouse which is right
there
and what was funny about rouse it was
that it was an alley effect it was a
small population with small plants so
what we think is happening is that a
large robust plant with 80 flowers per
year can tolerate
damage from mom fauxmance because it's
still gonna make fifty or sixty fruits
but a small plant in a bad year with no
second chance because it's an annual and
no ability to self pollinate that's when
the screws get tightened so that's what
we think after five years that's what we
think we're seeing it's really hard to
do this and coefficients are not very
satisfying but this is all the all the
assays together lead us to believe that
this is what's happened okay and so in
some plants eyes and whatever abiotic
factors influence plant size is probably
setting the context for whether this
hurts that okay so let me finish by
asking if we scale this up outside of
Colorado outside of this one species
that that we obsessed with for five
years do we see anything else that's
useful we see these patterns propagating
across the American West do we see in
John Thompson's parlance Geographic
mosaic of Co evolutionary processes so
here's the family on a Gracie I'm sorry
for the lack of confidence values but
this is a cartoon just to show you that
the ancestral condition for the whole
group is almost certainly be pollination
with one or two transitions to a
hummingbird pollination these are not
indicative of species richness fucsia is
a huge genus epilobium is a huge genus
just focusing on a you know thira here
so you know theory itself probably was
ancestrally be pollinated we have strong
support for a lot of these transitions
here and it looks like there was a there
was one major transition to hawk moth
pollination at the root of many of these
oenothera lineages and then they
translate to self pollination or knock
to it moth pollination or back to bees
so we wanted to capture some of this
diversity file ethically these are some
of the species that we worked with
including clark eeeh
the plant i worked with as a grad
student with one species out of 45's
hawk moth pollinated okay so there's
several different clades represented
here in our plan so what we wanted to do
was hit 15 different species
strategically chosen to represent you
know couplets closely related species
whose biology we suspected was going to
be very different and and here's their
relationships phylogenetically and what
you see here is that for each color bar
that's a species and each one of them
had three to five populations that we
went out sampled over five years and so
they're all color coded across the
American West now again not a bad place
to work
pretty amazing there's no normal years
right every year is different for
rainfall and for the early onset of
blooming or a great monsoon and
everything blooms again you know in the
Chihuahuan Desert in August the first
year of the project we had a September
bloom you just got to run and do it but
what we wanted to do was capture some of
that population level variation that we
had seen in oenothera herring Tony I out
here try to get sort of smaller versions
of that variation and as many other
species as we could and so our approach
was again to bring out large teams and
standardize the data collection floral
scent morphology nectar pollinator
visitation herb every Haley's eggs and
larvae mama in the buds and in the
fruits who worked in 58 populations many
many states this is a lot of work that
most of the budget of the project and
yet the players are so similar across
the whole family the same enemies the
same friends and so here's a quick look
a little all polymorphism extended well
beyond mean if they were hiring Tony I
differs among sibling species and among
populations with different species of
oenothera
so there's a couple of independent
origins of s plus little all we knew
about Clark your brewery because that's
what I studied as a grad student but
there's another one in the section
cattle office that accompany to switch
from hawk moth ancestry to be
pollination in West Texas okay then
there's a couple of examples here where
an ancestry is is likely a little el
producer and there's been an inferred
loss of our - little all okay here this
is a switch to be pollination this one
here
is still being pollinated by hawkmoths
like some of the populations of
oenothera herring Tony I this one here
in athira Brackett Carper has the
largest flowers and the genus it makes
no sense and it makes no sense
it is almost entirely vegetatively
propagating at this point and it's being
destroyed by mom feh so we don't know
how they're flying to finding the
flowers but but they've almost given up
on pollinator display and so the
question we asked is if you take all of
this data can we ask how to what extent
pollinators versus mom fuh are
structuring some of the data the
variation in the data sets so this is a
fight we're gonna do a file genetically
controlled multiple regression okay
and taking into account phylogenetic
distance Geographic distance pollinator
distance and and which species of mom
feh and the and the coefficients we got
for pollinators were both for morphology
and scent and for Mantha interestingly
enough even though we know that flower
trumpet flare matters to mom feh in that
this phylogenetic scale they were
explaining more variation in scent and
not so much in morphology so we had the
right to look at it now this is
basically a principal components
analysis of flower morphology across all
of our taxa and what you see here are
the be pollinated ones are clustering up
here in a Morpho space the high Lee's
small medium sized hawkmoth pollinated
ones are clustering over here and then
the ones with really long tongues and
tubes are clustering down here okay so
this is very pollinators are very nicely
explaining variation in more flow space
although each of these dots is a
different population and certainly in
many cases there's considerable
variation between populations of the
same species okay for scent these are
all hawk moth pollinated species and
they're all over the board okay so some
of them are making our little law but
that's not a strong predictor is
nitrogenous compounds down here there's
s little all up there so and and look at
also this
in Morpho space or in chemical space of
these populations of the same species
these guys are close these guys are not
okay whereas the be pollinated ones are
often the periphery they are really
leaving the chemical space so between
them we think we have a lot of structure
here here's what mama does alright
here's the same phylogenetic
relationships the pie charts if they're
blue mean that that species at least in
some populations has our - little wall
which we've been talking about all the
time if they're yellow they've switched
to s plus limb wall and we don't know
what that means
it's tracts moths but we don't know if
it attracts Mom feh
almost done um and then if they're gray
they've lost little all entirely and so
here the black bars show how many
populations in species X has infestation
from mom feh some species are free of
mom feh others are not and then we're
tracking the different kinds of month as
the flower bud galling ones and the seed
capsule galling ones so the good news is
there's an awful lot of stuff going on
here
the bad news is there's not a clear
direction of one mom for species driving
flowers to be silent removing scent
entirely and in fact there's other
species that are shifting to diurnal bee
pollination and are still getting
hammered by mom fuh okay
you would imagine that maybe those
flowers would be under selection to
close at night when Mom for active okay
so to wrap up what have we learned
little ole emission is certainly a
labile trait within population species
and sections of oenothera and I've shown
you that it's found across the world in
all kinds of other angiosperm families
little all appears to be selected
against by seed predator mom foe moths
without sacrificing Hailey's pollination
services which leads to the question of
why is little all needed at all and in
Eden Sara herring Tony I in similar
species it might be a phylogenetic
artifact is a shared derived trait in
that group of oenothera escaped from mom
from might involve the loss of little
all let's switch to a different
enantiomer of little all switch to be
pollination or switch to self
pollination
um and herbivores in some clearly play
important roles and complex roles as
selective agents on florals and
variation so I want to thank the big
team that we worked with in the field
over five years Amherst College Chicago
Botanic Garden and Warren Wagner from
the Smithsonian and certainly Jeff
broadhead so la buena and Deidre
Jacobson for helping us to to study some
of these interactions here in Cornell
during the year and our funding sources
and co-operators and thanks very much
look forward to questions right so this
is this is another prediction of the
geographic mosaic that not all not all
odors are attractive and there should be
strong selective pressure either to hide
or to push away we have to do the
experiments one of the it's interesting
that the second compound that showed up
in the qst FST analysis was Jasmine
lactone it's not a common compound in
flowers except in Jasmine but lactones
have a repellent quality in in in insect
control lactones can often be repellent
so that's a compound that we could
actually add to flowers and see if we
reduce mama attack the several of the
ones that had no mom for attacking them
actually produce lactones it's a good
question yeah that's a good question I
think that they have enough standing
variation in each population but that
the selection could act pretty quickly
we've wanted to do we were really
sensitive to the problem of not going to
the populations that make lentil all and
turning it off right I mean that would
be the
in baldwin way to do it is to use gene
silencing or to breed you know to
breathe uh the few individuals in those
populations that don't make little oh of
course there could be all kinds of other
things that are coming along with them
so you really do want a real it would
take a decade to make rolls with these
guys but a reciprocal transplant would
be interesting
I mean ethically he would want to every
move for pollen I would guess but you
certainly could look at bonfá attack on
plants from the Prairie that were grown
in Colorado Springs for plants from
Colorado Springs that were being grown
out in the Prairie to water them every
day would not work it is a parched Park
Place Sol and I went to work there this
spring and it was an unbelievable
drought there were no bees just a few
plants blooming it is the fate of the
West at the moment and and and Prairie
Colorado is becoming the Chihuahuan
Desert so a we we we were aware that we
wanted to do reciprocal transplants that
would have been a really nice experiment
to do yeah pie charts pie charts are
crude that's a great question what we in
in the publication that we're about to
submit we quantify so we do is is we
always have an internal standard in our
chromatography just to make sure that we
haven't injected the wrong amount but
then we run external standard curves for
all the major volatiles and we
quantitate them independently because in
mass spectrometry you have really
different response factors to the 70
electron volts
you know ionizing radiation so energy
rather so so yeah we quantitate them all
and we and we we try to eschew percent
of total we try to actually present
nanograms or micrograms per flower per
hour or per gram of flower per hour
potentially having different in
different concentrations yeah that's a
that's a great question the dose often
makes the
or the attractant in chemical ecology
what we found is that there are
plasticity issues when we grow the
plants from Florence which make huge
Peaks in our greenhouse with no UV okay
those Peaks fall fourfold in peak area
okay so we were conservative the amount
of little L that we added in the field
was the greenhouse amount and not the
field amount we were we were worried if
we added too much lintel all we'd have
some artifact of toxicity so we actually
chose you know we've lucked into
actually a an amount that we could add
in the evening that constituted a a
conservative test yeah no that's but
that's an important question a chemical
ecology you have to be very careful
which is why expressing a transgene in a
plant you know with an appropriate
amount of regulation you know could get
you the phenotype you want sure if
you're lucky great question
we did a transcriptomic study which I
didn't show here looking at expression
in stamens stigma petals buzz leaves etc
and we have all kinds of candidates for
an R - little synthase from this plant
the leaves don't emit very much there's
some Screaming candidates in leaves but
we don't get a lot of headspace coming
out of them other plants do we're
working with jewelweed right now which
makes little oh and it's leaves and not
so much in the flowers but this in this
point in this species the petals are
their source of lentil all the the
nectar tubes are nine centimeters long
and there's methyl benzoate in the
nectar but there's no little all in the
nectar but they're really separate
functional parts of the flower because
of that distance of thy pantheon so it's
a good question much lower amounts
variation and consider factors such as
environment UV radiation yes thank you
excellent we did we worried so these are
the little all producers these are the
little non producers this is an annual
average high temperatures okay for
across I guess we have three or four
populations of eh we didn't we didn't
get weather for all of them because some
of them are literally in the middle of
nowhere
um but precipitation there's no pattern
temperature there's no pattern winter
precipitation there's no pattern we also
looked at a principal components
analysis of soil okay they grow in silt
really fine grains and we looked at all
kinds of macronutrients and
micronutrients and and and particle size
no no clear explanation there yes
absolutely
Florence and a Pueblo Colorado are
coming up off the Prairie you know
they're they're probably like I mean
Colorado Springs uh seven Dells would
feet up right it's higher than Denver
whereas out in the Prairie it's like
nineteen 800 or 900 feet above sea level
so there's a considerable drop in
elevation so yep lots of UV out there
that's a very good point what's
fascinating is that all the other sent
compounds don't change well it all seems
to be the one that responds to UV but
that's an excellent point thank you yeah
so I so I should write a grant for UV
lamps all right thanks
[Applause]
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu